the anti tanking draft lottery reform
certainly took hold again as I mentioned
at the top of the show man was in the
room the room where it happened to use
the Hamilton phrase none other than
Howard Becket bleach report here on the
Rich Eisen show how are you Howard I'm
doing great how are you I'm good so okay
walk us through the whole process you
walk in you have to give up your cell
phone if you remember the media covering
the actual pulling of the ping-pong
balls right Howard that's what you are a
part of that group last night in Chicago
it yeah it's locked down it's sequester
it's and everybody who goes in at twelve
of us who are members of the media the
14 representatives of the teams right
people see the representatives on the
dais for the TV show there's a
corresponding rep from all those teams
in the sequester room where the actual
lottery ball draw happens and all of us
give up everything it's not just your
cell phone I couldn't bring in my
digital recorder even to do interviews
we could you know nothing your you go in
with a pad and pen immediate withdrawal
symptoms of not having my cell phone and
yeah then they start you know throw the
lottery balls in the the hopper and the
whole process begins but when you're in
the room it's the real order so the
first draw the first four ball
combination is the top pick so whereas
on TV you're watching the countdown and
all the drama that they've go up into it
when you're seeing the actual draw the
first four balls that come up correspond
to a combination it's on a big chart the
MBA rep looks it up and says New Orleans
and Alvin Gentry who's in the room for
the pelicans jumps up yells bleep yeah
it starts high-fiving people instantly
one of the greatest moments in NBA
lottery history that I have witnessed so
that was fun so yes so again we're
watching the video right now radio
audience and to you sir is is Alvin
Gentry just slapping hands with various
members of other organizations up there
so you are what you were in the room
watching Alvin Gentry just have that
reaction yes and like this is the third
time I've been in the room and normally
it's you know somebody might know
duel this pump or you know a little
prayer hands or something I Alvin that
was by far the most boisterous response
I have seen it was classic Alvin Gentry
so what happens do you think now Howard
I mean what what uh what what happened
do you think this means Anthony Davis
stays what goes through David Griffin's
mind right now
you know Grif had a philosophy going
into this before they even won the
lottery which is as the new GM as
somebody who is not responsible for the
you know screwed up situation that
caused an t Davis to ask out in the
first place Griss philosophy is going in
saying hey I'm gonna do everything
possible to convince Anthony Davis to
stay now that may be an impossible task
and I think a lot of people believe that
the outcome will not change Anthony
Davis will still be traded but David
Griffin has the chance to try to change
his mind even before this this
potentially helps whether it's drafting
as iron to play next to Anthony Davis
and that is a linchpin or whether it's I
can flip the Xion pick for a bunch of
players who can help Anthony Davis owl
you know all possibilities have to be on
the table in a good NBA team a smart NBA
team considers everything and while
people might already be howling saying
how could you trade the rights design
when you everybody can be traded you
like if yes that he could be the anchor
for a post Anthony Davis era but if you
think you could keep Anthony Davis who
is already a proven perennial all-star
we don't know sign Williamson will be by
the way but we know Anthony Davis is and
he's still in his prime if you could
find a way to keep him by trading Zion
Williamson's draft rights for a bunch of
players that can help Anthony Davis win
and convince him to stay you do that
explore everything well I mean we can
all explore everything the question is
you know how does that work that that
would be the wildest of all because that
would also be borne out of another rumor
that's spreading like crazy that Zions
unhappy about going into
New Orleans he wanted to go to New York
we did see him on on screen briefly
before before the lottery ESPN had a
camera on the on the screen and I mean
on the stage during the pregame show and
he walked up under the thing that
freaked me out is there was somebody
who's putting a ladder out there or just
folding up a ladder while he's walking
across the stage and I saw him tap the
Atlanta Hawks podium I'm everyone was
saying that I he maybe it was for good
luck or something he wanted to go there
Howard so what do you think is I on
potentially forcing his way out of New
Orleans or wants to or is thinking about
it what do you think about that
possibility
he can't kid I mean listen Anthony Davis
has leverage Anthony Davis is a
superstar on a effectively and expiring
contract so if you don't trade him and
he walks you're screwed we already saw
the cloud the toxic cloud that the
pelicans had over them once that trade
request was made public in the first
place so in Davis has leverage sign
Williamson has no leverage you know
you're drafted as a rookie and for
better or worse you have a minimum
three-year guaranteed contract set to
the rookie scale and the team holds an
option for the fourth year and for the
fifth year that you they have his rights
for five years now if they if sign
Williamson conveys that he does not want
to be there and the pelicans feel like
they could make a great deal and they
want to you honor that and trade it they
can resign Williamson can't demand it he
can't not show you there's no holdouts
in the NBA as a rookie you don't show up
you don't get paid and so you know we've
seen it before and yes you know many
years back Steve Francis drafted by the
Vancouver Grizzlies soaked about it got
himself traded you know before he ever
played there that was a long time ago in
a different era of the NBA I don't think
Sian Williamson can force his way
somewhere unless the pelicans decide
that that's what's in their best
interest so what's the timeframe on all
this because I mean you'd have to think
that if
David Griffin again the the general
manager of the pelicans determines that
Anthony Davis is a lost cause they're
gonna have to get get him out without
people knowing about it one would think
to try and keep the leverage going or if
he decides Anthony stays and the best
way to build around something right now
is to actually call somebody up for Zion
he's got to do this all sort of under
the radar how does this all time frame
out do you think Howard well it's the
NBA almost nothing's under the radar
anymore I mean very few trades actually
happen without something leaking out
about the talks and in this case there
are no secrets anyway because Anthony
Davis's agents rich Paul made the trade
demand public you know months ago and
there's been no indication that they
were moving off of that stance so it
whatever leverage you wanted to have is
gone anyway everybody knows what the
score is here that Anthony Davis wants
out and that he's on effectively a
one-year deal and so any team trading
for him
has to have some belief that they can
re-sign him now we've seen the Thunder
trade for Paul George when everybody
said Paul George wanted to be in LA and
they convinced him to stay we saw the
Raptors last year trade for Kawhi
Leonard that's paying off pretty well
right now even though they knew that he
supposedly wanted to go to LA and
they're still hoping that they can
resign him once David Griffin decides
assuming that this happens that Anthony
Davis does have to be moved that he's
not going to change his mind then grip
can start having those conversations
with people around the league and you
know any team that's interested and
there will be by the way more teams than
just Boston in the Lakers it's not going
to be just those two teams that were
talked about all this time there will be
other teams I guarantee it who will try
to make a move even if there's a
vacation well Anthony Davis wouldn't
resign and say Denver or Anthony Davis
says he wouldn't resign in you know
wherever fill in the blank all those
teams will I believe make an inquiry
they'll make an attempt because we've
we've seen this you trade for Paul
George you take your chances he might
resign and that is I think the lesson
for the bold teams
you take your chances and you bet on
yourself you bet on your organization
you'll be confident about it
and I think that the competition between
what four or five six however many teams
get into it will give Griffin enough
leverage to get the best deal powered
Becca bleacher report few more minutes
with with Howard here on the Rich Eisen
show and when you were in that draft
lottery room sitting there representing
the Knicks as Allan Houston so I guess
with Patrick on the outside now and on
the inside it was like the 1997-98
playoffs once again Howard with a big
fat loss for the Knicks sadly and
unfortunately what do they do now
obviously the number three overall
selection is not too shabby but what
does this mean for July 1st and all the
plans with porzingis which I guess is
one of the rare trades that went down
without anybody kind of hearing about it
what do you think I think that the
Knicks are in a much worse spot then
they hopes to be I think that's clear
now their plans this for the last
several months have been twofold one was
they created you know to Max slots to
try to sign two superstars this summer
and the other one was of course tanking
like crazy to try to get Diane
Williamson that part didn't work out the
three pick is fine but this is
considered basically a one man draft
there are people out there who are very
high on JAMA ranch there are others who
are not so maybe it's a two man draft I
have not heard anybody suggest as a
three man draft and it doesn't mean that
rj barrett or other guys couldn't
workout we've seen this many many times
obviously you know Yanis was the 15th
pick Kawhi was the 15th pick Rudy Gobert
the 27th pick there's somebody out there
that will fall lower and that people
slept on and turns out to be great but
are the Knicks now guaranteed to get a
changemaker at 3 no is that is that pick
and for trade purposes a great ship to
trade for Anthony Davis as the number
one pick would have been of course it's
not so you can't you can't really spend
this that was a loss for the Knicks and
that said no one will care probably if
they sign Kevin Durant and another star
on July 1st and that remains you know
their primary and the most important
path they put a lot of you know a lot of
chips
into that particular pot it's all about
trying to get superstars to come and
sign with all the cap room they've got
if they can do that then you know
they're they're in good shape if they
can't you know they've got some young
players already who haven't really done
much and they'll have the third pick and
whoever that becomes and it'll be a long
haul and then you know hey the Lakers
they lucked out you could say I mean
they've got the fourth overall selection
now when everybody thought it would be
way down the list what what do you what
do you think is a guy who obviously
covers the the league nationally and
used to cover the Lakers specifically
the Vogel and Kidd hiring and now going
into the summer with the fourth overall
selection in their back pocket and
LeBron seeking a Help Wanted sign out
front for him to try and win another
title what do you think the Lakers
standing is now that we're through the
draft lottery well jumping from 11th to
force with the lottery was huge for them
Rob pálinka he was in the room and he
you know immediately you know shook
hands his celebration was a little more
muted than Alvin Gentry's shook hands
with two people to his left and right
and put his hands together and kind of a
praying motion and thankful to have
moved up having the fourth pick is great
I don't think it's in the Lakers
interest to necessarily to use that pick
you you've got LeBron James you need to
win now rookies don't usually help you
win or contend in this league it's very
very rare and certainly the fourth pick
is not going to help they've already got
young players in Lonzo and Brandon
Ingram they've you know they were
already too young to be good enough this
past season now those guys got another
year of experience under their belts and
the Lakers will try once again I'm sure
to chase Anthony Davis is the fourth
overall pick plus the stuff they've got
you know the players that they've got
that the pelicans already rejected will
it be enough I don't know I mean David
Griffin's the GM in New Orleans now
instead of Dell Demps does that change
the evaluation from the New Orleans side
of it well they we engage with the
Lakers the Lakers need immediate help
whether that's signing another max
player the summer they do have room for
one super
whether it's finding somebody to come
play with LeBron whether it's flipping
some of their young guys for if it's not
Anthony Davis then maybe somebody else
becomes available maybe it's Bradley
Beal maybe it's somebody else you know
that we haven't you know even thought of
yet they need immediate help if they're
not going to waste what's left of
LeBrons career and his contract there
the Lakers need immediate veteran proven
help and that's the task for them this
summer so they in it so based on what
you were saying at the outset of our
conversation Alvin Gentry found out
first that he was first and then the
Grizzlies found out second that they
were second meaning the Knicks the
Knicks Cavs and and Sun started sweating
bullets on the spot and then Alan
Houston in the next like wiped their
brow hey at least they got three and
that's when Rob polenka found out that
the last fourth spot actually was theirs
and that's the way that it all ended in
the room last night yeah yeah they go in
order so yes you knew the pelicans were
splatted first and then the Grizzlies
turned up they were slotted second then
the next find out they're slotted third
and then the Grizzlies numbers came up
again you know you're signed at you know
a certain number of combinations and so
the Grizzlies actually came up again
through the fourth draw and and but but
that that happens sometimes and so what
they do is they say the Grizzlies
okay we'll draw again they throw the
balls back in the machine they bounce
around they pull it all out again and
then the Lakers combination came up and
that's when Rob pálinka knew okay we've
got the fourth pick so there was there
was one you know so then the last thing
for you here Howard the Lakers had a
nine point four percent chance of
getting a top four pick Memphis at
twenty six point three percent of
getting a top four pick and they went
ahead and had it in getting hit twice
with those odds then you have Phoenix
and Cleveland with a 52% of a top four
pick neither of them getting one so
overall what does the NBA think about
this yes they got a great show on ESPN
last night and everybody tweeting about
it and buzzing about this and yes maybe
teams will think twice about tanking
next year but teams that need the help
the most aren't getting it so the teams
that are terrible don't have the leg up
to actually get better which is the
purpose of a draft Howard where does the
NBA stand on all this do you think today
it's the right question and this is what
the NBA has been grappling with for
years ever since they created the
lottery in the first place if you go
with a straight reverse order drafts
with no lottery then of course you
completely incentivize teams to tank to
get to the top pick so you create a
lottery then you tweak the lottery odds
and then years later you tweak them
again and the whole thing with the
system is trying to find that balance of
still trying to help the teams that need
to help the most that lost the most
games of the prior season without
incentivizing teams to actually lose on
purpose and in this era of analytics
where everybody can can you know figure
out everything down to the last decimal
you people started to explode in a way
that was you know beyond what we'd ever
seen right tanking has always existed it
just became I think a little more
pronounced in the last five or so years
and it freaked the league out and they
don't like here's the thing that they
hate the most I mean there's there's two
aspects they don't like a team game
trying to gain the system that that's
already bad it seemed just you know
structuring themselves to lose on
purpose is is not good but the part that
I think really bothers Adam silver is
when fans are behind it when Philly fans
were actually cheering for the Sixers to
lose year after year and you saw it this
year again Knicks fans I've never seen
Knicks fans so completely complacent
about a 17 win season and the next event
a lot of bad seasons this is the first
time since I've been in New York for 15
years then I can remember Knicks fans
based at it's fine it's fine we're
getting Zion and that is what the NBA
rejiggering the lottery odds was is
intended to combat so now you get burned
by it not just the Knicks but the Suns
and the Cavs too you get burned by it
and now fans will be presumably less
likely to be cheering for their teams to
lose next season knowing it could
backfire and if the fans aren't behind
you then it's harder for the GM
to try this in the first place or to
sell it because then every no one has to
face that it's going to work out and
that that's the the uncertainty that you
need and so if this lottery did anything
hopefully it has in fact discouraged
tanking and and fans from rooting for
that for that strategy and I think
that's a good outcome overall for the
league and there are people in the room
last night that was the first thing they
said to me these were you know team reps
who were like you know what this is this
is good for the league it's good that it
happened this way and I would still say
this by the way yeah the sons and calves
and Knicks who were the bottom three
teams and record and none of them got
the top pick they all slid but the teams
that got to the top the pelicans and
Grizzlies are teams that need help I
mean I know the pelicans have Anthony
Davis but they didn't make the playoffs
they did you know they do have to trade
him they do need help anyway the
Grizzlies certainly needs help and you
know teams are just gonna have to build
differently and not count on the idea of
a top three pick Howard you the man
thanks for the time we'll chat soon
before the finals for sure you got ATS
Howard back bleacher report had Howard
back for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app